Tổ thủ quên nào ở vừa đi via zenski ngay hát lập tháng 8 cho biết ông và thống thống miy đồn năng trăm đảnh nhất chỉ rằng
bông cao phán ba bên tiếp theo dưới quên à, mi và ngá trong tháng ba, tân tạo tiền để cho một cuộc gặp lãnh đảo,
nhằm thuộc đời tiền trình trong rất súng đột đạo bước sáng năm.
Phó biểu sắc của định đạo bước trăm, một zenski cho hại các cuộc thủ lượng ba bên dưới kiến dễ ra và đột tháng tới.
Chào đỏ phái đoàn quên nào và miy sẽ học sống phương ta junet để thảo lận các vấn đề tạo thiệt hậu chiến,
cho đột tụi bên và một gói trình vượng tình tế, kia bước tính cần khoảng 30% tìm đồ lắm Mỹ trong 1 năm để phục hồi đất nước.
Trong khi đánh giảm mời của ngân hát thế giới nếu chi khi tài thiết lên tới năm trong tảm tìm tảm tìm đồ lắm Mỹ,
tình đến quой năm 2 nhìn của trường hành lắm.
Nhà lính đạo của quên nào nhìn mạnh trở nạn nhìn này không nằm ở kia cảnh con sức mà ở ít xin trị và bình đề lạnh thổ.
Khi lập trường giữa kia tở mắt sức và vẫn còn cách bi lớn, ông đồng thời bác bỏ cáo bước của ngà dàng,
của quên nào đang tìm cách sở hiệu của khàn nhân cho rằng đây là nỗ lực gây sức áp trong đảm tự phản.
Tự phía ngà, nếu phóng đẹp sở n類 gì mình trị bắt sốt cho rằng,
một cuộc gặp thận đình chỉ nên dễn ra khi các thỏ thận đợp trình bị ký lớm ở cấp trình ra
đông thời đất câu hỏi về tính khả thị của đối thoại để lập trường về lạnh thổ không thể đôi.